(pensive music)
- [Adam] Cisco's revamped New York office
is packed with technology.
There's tech that tracks.
- There's 5,000 individual data points
that are being constantly
collected and harvested
in this facility.
- And tech use for collaboration.
Is there any space
in this office that doesn't have a camera?
- No, there isn't.
- [Adam] Cisco's smart
office is both a showcase
of the company's technology and an example
of how it sees the workplace evolving.
So how does it look?
And more importantly, how does it work?
I took a tour with the project's leaders
and popped into a few
meetings to find out.
(meeting participants chuckling)
Cisco's 59,000 square foot office sits
in midtown Manhattan in One Penn Plaza,
exactly where it's been
for the last 17 years.
But in the last two,
it's undergone an $18
million tech-driven redesign.
- This is one of the few projects
where technology was really
at the very beginning
and pervasive throughout
the entire process.
- In this space, the screens, cameras
and sensors came before
the lighting and furniture,
which was a new process
for both Gensler and Cisco.
- We really think technology
is gonna be at the heart
of how people design
buildings moving forward.
So we started it with that layer.
- To see this tech,
all you have to do is look up.
The ceiling is littered with
tech, each of which doing more
than it might appear.
So hard to miss this camera.
What is this camera doing?
- Actually, this was a
Meraki security camera
and obviously, it's
recording people coming in
and out of the floor,
but it's also got a trip wire built in.
We can actually count people
as they come in and
decrement as they leave.
So at any given time,
we know the overall
occupancy of the floor.
- [Adam] But to know where people are
after they enter the office,
Cisco uses its wireless
access points like this one.
- It's actually tracking
mobile devices as a proxy
for understanding occupancy
of space and people
but it's also tracking air quality,
temperature, and humidity.
- Is it tracking my
mobile device right now?
- Yeah, it's tracking a mobile device.
It doesn't know it's you
but it knows there are
two mobile devices here
because I have one in my pocket as well.
- Leave the hallway to enter a meeting
and the cameras used to
connect employees on video call
then pick up the count, tracking
the number of participants
in the room.
While employees may be anonymous,
this type of tracking isn't common.
Just 1% of companies
in a 2022 Gartner poll have
sensors that track foot traffic.
43% of companies say
they aren't tracking
onsite attendance at all.
Are employees at all concerned
about the tracking that's possible
in an office where
cameras count the number
of bodies in the space?
- No, I don't believe they are.
And the reason for that is at Cisco,
we don't have a set number
of days that we expect
employees to be in the office.
I think if we had different
expectations around being
in the office, it may feel
a little bit different
but because we don't,
I think they understand
that those insights allow us
to make the space the best
that it can be for them.
- [Adam] Still, these are Cisco products.
Other companies that purchase
these systems could use them
for more specific tracking or
they could do as Cisco does
and feed the data here
for employees to see.
- Really what we have
here is the great ability
to show employees space availability.
Red is obviously a space that is booked
and being used right now, or
Amber is a space that's booked
and not being used and
green is an available space.
- Let's find a space that we can go to.
- Yeah, so here's a space right here.
- We'll go to this space.
- Okay.
- Let's hold that.
And that's gonna give us four
minutes to get over there.
- [Adam] Four minutes
because in this office,
space is meant to be shared.
So rooms like the ones lining
this hall aren't bookable.
The red and green lights are your signal.
- See, this is our room
that we're gonna use.
Yep.
- All right.
These ad hoc spaces represent one
of the biggest changes to
Cisco's space: how it's balanced.
Take a look at Cisco's floor plan.
These spaces are what Cisco
considers individual workspaces.
These spaces are for teams.
- In the past, our building
was set up where 70%
of the space was targeted
toward individuals
and 30% of the space was
targeted toward teams.
And we flipped that.
- [Adam] That resulted in
the 90 collaboration spaces
seen here and left just
50 individual desks.
- I think this is a new era and I think
that when you want to sit by
yourself and get work done,
you may not choose the office to do that.
- [Adam] There are actually
about 1,700 employees assigned
to this office but Cisco doesn't expect
that they'll all be in on the same day.
- With hybrid here to stay,
we're seeing so much more emphasis
on amenity spaces, collaboration spaces.
People are coming in to
be with other people.
The things that they can't do
when they're working at home.
- [Adam] Things like
brainstorming on a whiteboard
or meeting in a 14-person
room like this one
are now the focus.
- So what's really interesting
about this space is how the space design,
how the furnishings and the
technology all come together.
- [Adam] They come together
because Cisco designed the
table to work specifically
with the camera at the other end,
from the placement of the
microphones to this matte finish,
which helps reflect light up
onto the faces of the table.
Most noticeable though is
the table's tapered shape.
- We shape the table to make
sure everybody has a line
of sight on the display
and can see content.
And we also make sure
that people that are
remote that are joining us
actually have line of sight
of everybody at the table.
- Right, because that person
all the way at the end
is much further to the right than I am.
So they should be able
to see every single face
down the road.
That shape and the exclusion of chairs
on the screen side is pervasive
in Cisco's space because it says 98%
of its meetings will have
a remote participant.
So who is this conference
room designed for?
Is it designed for the people who are here
at this table or is it designed
for the people who are
signing in remotely?
- When we think about
designing collaboration spaces
like this, we spend as much time
if not more about worrying
about the remote participant.
We wanna make sure there's
absolute digital equality.
- [Adam] Digital equality,
that's an idea that Cisco stressed
and something it thinks
its hybrid workforce needs.
- Something that we have all experienced
is sometimes you're in a meeting
and you're having a hard time breaking in
and especially if you
happen to be the only one
in the office or the only
one working remotely.
- And here's where the
camera can help bring people
or at least their faces closer.
I tested it with colleagues who work
in two separate offices.
Are you seeing this full room?
Are you seeing this whole table?
- No, I'm seeing four chairs.
- Same. I just sent you a screen grab.
- Oh, okay.
- Yeah.
- So you're really only seeing
like my side of the room.
There is an argument to
be made that with all
of Cisco's technology and the
ability to make every space
into a hybrid meeting
space that the office
isn't really needed at all.
What would you say to that?
- Well, I think that
at the end of the day,
people will want to come together
but they're gonna come
together for different reasons.
- But for those who'd rather stay home
the tech is here to support that.
And that's an example that
other companies may follow.
So do you expect other
companies you work with
to want to do tech first, design second?
- Absolutely, I mean, so many
of our clients are interested
in seeing this space because
of how this was built.
I think anyone that's
looking to build a new space
is gonna think this way.
(pensive music)